we mentioned today is Veterans Day and
this morning a Las Vegas tradition
resumes downtown it's the annual parade
right through the center of the city
Dixon Keller is joining us live this
morning from downtown Las Vegas he's
from the veterans Action Group which
helps organize the event and Dixon joins
us now once again Dixon good to see you
once again thanks for joining us this
morning let's talk about the parade and
and what people are going to be seeing
once again this year
this is going to be a big comeback for
the parade this year because we've had
some slower years because of the
pandemic but we're going strong this
year with close to 5 000 people alone in
the parade and of course we're the
second largest veterans parade in the
nation a lot of kids a lot of bikes in
the parade desk this year which is kind
of unique and this is going to be a very
exciting parade
beautiful day a little chilly but this
is a day you want to come down to Fourth
Street and cheer on our veterans
yeah for the folks that are sitting out
in the sun on 4th Street it'll feel
warmer eventually uh you know Dixon I I
see the parade it goes right by where I
live every year which is fantastic to
see just why is you know you mentioned
how big it is here in Las Vegas maybe
let's talk about the importance of
honoring our veterans today for their
service and how a parade like this can
can really do wonders
well you know veterans basically join
voluntarily we don't have a draft
anymore so people join to do jobs that
sometimes can be thankless and
especially for our Vietnam veterans
which I'm a Vietnam vet when we came
back nobody said thank you for your
service but now we have a lot of people
who are thankful for our veterans and
for the job that they do not only
putting putting themselves Every Day In
Harm's Way But even doing humanitarian
work because the military does so many
different things and it's great for kids
when they join they can learn a vocation
a job discipline and I'll tell you when
I went in I learned so much it was
really shaped my life and this is a
great day for veterans to honor one
another for people to say thank you to
varins for their service uh it's so good
to hear nowadays and of course it's
great for kids because it's called
generational continuity where kids can
come out of the parade and they can
watch the veterans and see history go
right by them which is so awesome my
father's a veteran I learned a lot from
him as well and Dixon thank you for your
service as well enjoy the parade later
today looking forward to it take care of
yourself